monsieur drouet qui est aujourd'hui
secrétaire général de la coordination
nationale du renseignement à la
présidence de la république n'est pas
convoqué au titre de cette fonction mais
au titre de la fonction qu'il exerçait
antérieurement celle de chef de cabinet
du préfet de police de paris
et c'est à ce titre que nous allons le
questionner dans le cadre du mandat qui
est le nôtre
monsieur drouet comme je le fais à
chaque fois car c'est notre règle je
dois vous rappeler qu'un faux témoignage
devant notre commission des lois doté
des prérogatives d'une commission
denquête serait passible de cinq ans
d'emprisonnement et de 75000 euros
d'amande et je vous invite à prêter
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité levé la main droite et dit je
le jure je le jure je vous remercie
souhaitez vous introduire cette audition
par un propos liminaire un cours propos
liminaires et bien vous avez la parole
monsieur le président monsieur les co
rapporteurs
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
comment
messieurs du coup rapporte maintenant
madame monsieur madame monsieur échos
rapportés je suis devant vous
aujourd'hui au titre de mes précédentes
fonctions de chef de cabinet du préfet
de police de paris un poste que j'ai
occupé de janvier 2016 au 27 avril 2010
huit jeunes occupe aujourd'hui les
fonctions de secrétaire général de la
coordination nationale du renseignement
et de la lutte contre le terrorisme
depuis le 30 avril 2018 j'insiste un
moment sur ces dates parce que n'étant
plus en fonction la préfecture de police
le 1er mai 2018 et n'ayant pas été
impliqué dans la préparation de la
gestion de la manifestation de ce 1er
mai je n'étais pas informé de la
participation d'alexandre benalla en
tant qu'observateur et je ne pourrai
donc rien vous dire sur ces faits qui
ont été l'élément déclencheur de votre
commission d' enquête avant de répondre
à vos questions
je tiens à rappeler les missions qui
étaient les miennes en tant que chef de
cabinet du préfet de police de paris
tout d'abord la gestion de l'agenda et
des dossiers du préfet de police ainsi
que des nombreuses interventions qui lui
sont adressés ensuite la gestion rh et
budgétaires du cabinet du préfet de
police
après la supervision de la direction de
la police générale de la préfecture de
police au titre du cabinet du préfet et
donc de l'ensemble des sujets dont elle
est en charge avec notamment le droit
des étrangers les naturalisations les
papiers d'identité et permis de conduire
les cartes grises et diverses polices
administratives notamment celles liées
aux armes
vient ensuite la mission de pilotage de
la sécurité la sûreté du site principal
de la préfecture de police sur l'île de
la cité et enfin l'organisation des
déplacements des hautes personnalités ou
des grands événements sur paris avec
notamment la coordination des différents
services de sécurité impliquées lors de
ces événements le lien avec la chef les
chefferies de cabinet des personnes des
hautes personnalités concernées et aussi
avec les héros organisateurs éventuel
d'événements à ce titre
j'étais le contact naturel normal de la
chefferie de cabinet de la présidence de
la république pour la préparation et
l'organisation des déplacements du
président de la république sur paris je
suis maintenant à votre disposition pour
répondre à vos questions
je vous remercie madame de patates
monsieur monsieur super merci beaucoup
monsieur le président monsieur le chef
de cabinet je vous appeler comme ça
puisque c'est à ce titre que nous vous
auditionnons comme l'a dit le président
même si nous n'ignorons pas que vous
exercer d'autres fonctions présentement
donc je vais vous interrogez uniquement
sur le permis de port d'armes qui a été
délivré à monsieur benalla madame jourda
posera toute une série d'autres
questions
en complément de d'abord ce permis de
port d'armes dont nous avons le document
et vous connaissez ce document puisqu'il
a été rédigée je pense par aux soins ou
sous votre contrôle
voilà il est étrange à beaucoup d'égards
et je voulais vous demander d'abord qui
en a formellement fait la demande au nom
de la présidence de la république
tu devrais monsieur le co-rapporteur
c'est une question importante et qui
nécessite que je prenne le temps de
répondre pour détailler l'ensemble de la
procédure
le 5 octobre 2017
les services de la direction de la
police générale de la préfecture de
police
m'informe de la réception d'une demande
de port d'armes de la part de monsieur
benalla chargé de mission à la
présidence de la république
en l'absence de directeur au sein de
cette direction le
le post était tout simplement vacances à
cette période là les services souhaite
que le cabinet du préfet de police
évoque le dossier à son niveau c'est
donc par l'intermédiaire des services
administratifs de la préfecture de
police que je prends connaissance de
cette demande
j'informe alors le préfet de police qui
me demande de me rapprocher du cabinet
du président de la république afin que
le dossier nous parviennent par la voie
hiérarchique le 10 octobre 2010 est le
directeur du cabinet du président de la
république confirme la demande par
courriel et sollicite son examen sur le
fondement de l'article l 315 tirer 1 du
code de la sécurité intérieure et ce
essais marqués dans le courriel de
transmission dans le strict respect des
textes
ce sont là les seuls liens que nous
avons eues avec le cabinet du président
de la république sur ce dossier et me
paraît utile de faire un point sur les
textes mobilisés dans cet arrêté si vous
me permettez l'article l 315 tirer 1 du
code de la sécurité intérieure dispose
que les fonctionnaires et agents des
administrations publiques exposé par
leurs fonctions à des risques
d'agression peuvent être autorisées à
fermer dans le cadre de leurs fonctions
ces dispositions sont codifiés dans le
code de la sécurité intérieure et j'en
viens aux articles qu'on va mentionné
dans l'arrêté l'article l311 300 12-24
du code précité dispose que les
fonctionnaires et agents des
administrations publiques chargées d'une
mission de police et où et ou exposées à
des risques d'agression peuvent être
autorisés à acquérir et à détenir des
armes
la situation d'alexandre benalla
correspondant à ce cas de figure nous
avons donc lancé à ce moment là
l'instruction du dossier
en veillant à réunir l'ensemble des
pièces nécessaires le carnet tirer
formation continue le certificat médical
l' enquête de moralité et c'est après un
examen approfondi du dossier
il est apparu que le dossier était
complet et que les missions de monsieur
pénale à rentrer dans le cadre fixé par
le législateur
ainsi considérant l'action d'alexandre
benalla de coordination de sécurité de
la présidence de la république avec les
forces militaires et le gspr considérant
qu'il exerçait sa mission auprès du
président de la république qui fait
l'objet de nombreuses menaces et dans un
contexte au niveau de menace terroriste
n'a jamais été aussi élevé et
considérant qu'ils étaient de fait
manifestement exposés à des risques
d'agression
c'est ça qui est écrit dans l'arrêté le
préfet de police a validé sa demande les
j'ai signé le 13 octobre 2007 par
délégation du préfet de police
l'autorisation de port d'armes de
monsieur benalla une autorisation que
nous avons limité strictement à
l'exercice de ses missions et à la
validité de son contrat à la présidence
de la république
mais monsieur drouet
j'entends ce que vous dites mais
monsieur le secrétaire général de
l'elysée monsieur le directeur de
cabinet du président de la république et
monsieur le chef de cabinet nous ont
affirmé que monsieur benalla n'exerçait
pas de missions de police
tout le monde ici a entendu cela or je
me suis déjà étonné auprès d'eux comme
je m'étonne auprès de vous que le permis
de port d'armes portent la mention
suivante je crois que notre président en
disposent considérant que monsieur e
benalla est chargé d'une mission de
police
alors c'est clair c'est net et c'est
précis alors autre question vous avez
dit que la demande a été faite par un
courriel ce matin même monsieur benalla
nous a dit qu'elle avait été faite par
téléphone
s'il s'agit d'un courriel je suppose que
ce courriel existe toujours
car nous nous avons demandé le document
par lequel l'elysée
donc le directeur de cabinet a demandé
le port d'armes et il a été refusé de
nous communiquer cette pièce est ce que
vous disposez toujours je suppose que
vous ne disposez pas de ce courriel mais
je suppose que dans les archives de la
préfecture de police
ils figurent et est-ce que vous avez le
souvenir précis des mentions qui
figurait sur ce courriel parce que de
deux choses l'une où ce sont ce les
mentions c'est que monsieur benalla
exerce des missions de police
et cela invalide les déclarations qui
ont été faites à la fois par le
secrétaire général le directeur de
gamine et le chef de cabinet ou alors on
ne comprend pas
cédric vous allez pas vous avez la part
des choses il ya une question en deux
temps je vais je vais commencer par la
seconde qui est le courriel je le
confirme
sous serment c'est un courriel du
directeur de cabinet du président rick
qui a déclenché l'instruction du dossier
dans ce courriel je le cite de mémoire
ça fait un certain temps et je en
quelques il y avait marqué que l'on
n'avait été informé de cette demande que
monsieur strzoda confirmé cette demande
et qu'ils nous demandait de l'instruire
sur le fondement de l'article l 315
tirer 1 du code de la sécurité
intérieure et ce dans le strict respect
des textes
point final c'est la transmission avec
toutes les pièces justificatives au
dossier voilà qui peut paraître
surprenant qu'il soit nécessaire que le
directeur de cabinet précise que c'est
dans le strict respect des textes qui
vous demande d'instruire une demande de
permis de port d'armes
parce que ça pourrait aller deux fois on
pourrait imaginer que ça va de soi plaît
6 et les choses par deux fois le
ministère de l'intérieur a refusé le
port d'armes en étiez vous informer
[Musique]
je n'étais pas informé des refus opposé
par le ministère de l'intérieur
et ça n'a rien d'anormal ça n'a rien
d'anormal parce qu'on est sur des
fondements juridiques différents le
ministère de l'intérieur instruit la
dame les demandes de port d'armes pour
une personne exposée à des risques
exceptionnels d'atteinte à sa vie sur la
base de l'article r 300 15-5 du code de
la sécurité intérieure les préfets des
départements et à paris le préfet de
police instruisent de leur côté les
demandes de port d'armes des
fonctionnaires et agents publics chargés
d'une mission de police et où exposer à
des risques d'agression dans le cadre de
leurs fonctions sur le fondement de
l'article r 312 tiré 24 du code de la
sécurité intérieure c'est sur ce second
fondement que la préfecture de police a
été saisie et c'est sur ce second
fondement que le dossier a été instruit
dans le strict respect des compétences
du préfet de police
il n'y avait aucune raison d'interroger
le ministère de l'intérieur sur le sujet
ambre de la chefferie de cabinet il y
avait donc quatre personnes bénéficient
aussi d'un permis de port d'armes durant
les deux ans et demi que j'ai passé à la
préfecture de police
c'est la seule demande que nous avons
reçu de la part de la présidence de la
république
ne trouvez-vous pas étrange que
l'adjoint au chef de cabinet bénéficient
de ce port d'armes est pas eu le chef de
cabinet adjoint ni le chef de cabinet
j'ai pas porter de jugement de valeur ce
qui me revenait ce qui revenait aux
services de la préfecture de police
s'étaient de juger si la demande était
fondée en droit
la demande a été jugée a été jugé fondé
en droit et donc on ya répondu
on répond aux question qu'on nous pose
après je vais pas tirer de plans sur
d'éventuelles demandes qui auraient pu
éventuellement nous parvenir avez vous
le souvenir que dans le courriel le
directeur de cabinet faisait état de
missions de police stricto sensu
très clairement non il n'était pas fait
état de missions de police et je le
répète il faut lire ses considérants en
entier dans leur ensemble
il ya un certain nombre de considérants
est isolé isolé un passage il ne permet
pas de comprendre
attendez je vais je vais expliquer je
vais expliquer parce qu'il faut être
très clair c'est marquer et c'est écrit
dans l'arrêté
c'est dans le cadre de son action de
coordination de la sécurité de la
présidence de la république avec les
forces militaires et le j'espère que les
services de la préfecture de police que
nous avons estimé
nous avons estimé à la préfecture de
police que son action pouvait s'inscrire
dans une mission de police
on a ensuite qualifié le niveau de
menace dans le cas d' exercer sa mission
en parlant d'un haut niveau de la menace
terroriste et la sensibilité du domaine
d'exercice de sa mission aux côtés d'une
très hautes personnalités parmi les plus
menacés de france et nous avons donc
considéré que dans le cadre de sa
mission
il était manifestement exposés à des
risques d'agression
c'est pour l'ensemble de ces raisons et
sur en s'inspirant de l'article r 300
12-24 qui parle de mission de police et
de là que vient le terme y sont de
police faut pas chercher c'est de
séparer ses deux premiers alinéas de
l'arrêté de l'article excusez moi r 312
tient et 24 du code de la sécurité
intérieure que nous avons considéré que
les missions exercées par
monsieur ban à la rentrée dans le cadre
fixé par le législateur
ea dont le préfet de police a donc
validé son port d'armes juste une
seconde sur le service qui instruit ce
type de demande
c'est la direction de la police générale
direction de la police générale mais la
direction de la police générale à la
préfecture de police
il n'y a pas un seul policier au sein de
la direction de la police générale
malgré le terme peut police c'est une
direction strictement administrative et
pour cette direction il n'y a jamais eu
aucune ambiguïté sur le sujet en tant
que je reviens sur le fait que le chef
de cabinet qui exercé strictement si
j'ai bien compris des missions de
présence très proche du président de la
république pouvait être considérée comme
été comme étant et autant exposée à des
questions de risque d'autre part si je
comprends bien vous ne verriez pas
d'inconvénient à ce que le curry le
courriel nous fut communiqué ben en fait
l avons bon valeur si nous l'avons dit
en revanche en revanche pour préciser la
question de notre rapporteur ce courriel
est fait état d'une note jointe
et curieusement et je crois que c'est ça
que vous vouliez dire monsieur n'importe
qui et la note jointe aux courriels
n'est pas jointe à la communication du
courriel et donc nous souhaitons avoir
ce document bien évidemment est par
ailleurs la demande initiale puisque ce
courriel fait état d'une demande qui lui
tu antérieures qu'il a quelqu'un qui le
précède la demande initiale ne l'avons
pas non plus je pense que compte de ce
que vous nous expliquer ce document
permettrait peut-être d' établir
définitivement que c'est pour la
sécurité personnelle de monsieur benalla
que la demande a été faite il suffirait
de le vérifier en
n'accédant à ce document monsieur drouet
le dossier de port d'armes ayant été
saisi par la justice je n'ai pas pu le
retourner dedans pour faire les archives
donc je ne n'ai pas en mémoire les
éléments qu'il y avait dans cette note
d'accompagnement dernière question pour
ma part il est fait état dans le
document donnant le port d'armes
autorisant au port d'armes des du fait
que monsieur benalla deux disposent de
la possibilité de diriger un organisme
de sécurité privée oui c'est je crois
que monsieur le président pourra
confirmer car elle dispose du document
et pourquoi pas là la question est toute
simple pourquoi cette se considérant
pourquoi se considérant pas ce que
monsieur benalla était connu des
services de la préfecture de police dans
le cadre de céder dans le cadre de
détention et d'acquisition d'armes et de
port d'armes dans le cas de ses
anciennes fonctions en marche de chef du
service de la sécurité et donc il y
avait tout un dossier qui existait un
fonds dossier qui existait sur monsieur
benalla et ça permettait de fin c'était
un considérant qu'ils étaient inutiles
l'humain c'est un peu inutile dans
l'arrêté qu'on avait mis parce qu'il y
avait un titre à titre décoratif
parce que finalement la demande du port
d'armes ne se justifier que par les
fonctions qu'il exerçait à l'elysée
exclusivement pour elle chez achevé mais
question oui je vais continuer si vous
voulez bien également sur le sur le port
d'armes
vous nous avez indiqué que la demande de
permis de port d'armes a été déposée le
5 octobre 2017 tout cas vous en avez été
informé à cette date là quelle forme
avait pris cette demande initiale
puisqu'elle n'était manifestement pas
fait par voie hiérarchique
là c'est à la préfecture de police et un
service public et en tant que service
public la préfecture de police à
différents guichet pour les différentes
procédures que les administrés veulent
donner auprès de la préfecture
monsieur benalla s'est adressé au
guichet de la préfecture de police qui
est une démarche normale dans dans le
cadre de ce type de demande
j'insiste j'insiste sur ce point mais je
vais y revenir
ça montre quoi si on reprend l'ensemble
de la chronologie des événements ça
montre que la machine d'état bien
fonctionné monsieur benalla s'adresse
aux guichets de la préfet des services
administratifs de la préfecture de
police qui vont un collaborateur du
président de la république faire une
demande de port d'armes qu'est-ce qu'ils
font des alertes des alertes
le cabinet du préfet de police et le
préfet de police directement que fait-on
au niveau du cabinet de préfet de police
on informe la hiérarchie on met dans la
boucle la hiérarchie de monsieur benalla
pour demander est ce que vous les
transmettre
si elle me demande ça doit venir par la
voie hiérarchique la demande est
confirmé par la hiérarchie de monsieur
benalla et c'est sur cette base que nous
lançons l'instruction du dossier
ça montre tout simplement qu'il ya eu un
fonctionnement administratif efficace st
est totalement transparent l'âme jourda
oui je persiste sur sur ce permis de
port d'armes
j'ai cru comprendre mais vous allez me
dire si c'est bien le sens de votre
intervention tout à l'heure que vous
nous avez indiqué que dans les
considérants de ce permis qui visait les
missions de police
ces missions étaient visés tout
simplement parce qu'elle figurait dans
l'article r 300 12-24 du code de la
sécurité intérieure qui les prévoit donc
en fait c'était une reprise pure et
simple du texte
c'est bien cela que vous nous avez
indiquée c'est bien ça que je vous ai
indiqué
le premier alinéa de l'article r 300
12-24 dispose que les fonctionnaires et
agents publics chargés de missions de
police peuvent être armés
le deuxième alinéa dispose que les
agents des fonctionnaires publics
manifestement exposés à des risques
d'agression dans le cadre de leurs
fonctions peuvent être armés
le dans l'écriture dans l'écriture
peut-être maladroite de de cet arrêté
on a repris premier alinéa considérant
que monsieur benalla exerce des missions
de police et on le qualifie on s'arrête
pas dire qu'il est conscient qu'il dans
le cadre de son action de coordination
des services de sécurité de la
présidence de la république en lien avec
les forces militaires et le gspr et
ensuite on prend le deuxième alinéa et
on dit que dans le cas de ces missions
il est manifestement exposés à des
risques d'agression en raison et celle
d'annie lanières précédent du haut
niveau de menace poursuit sur ce point
parce que j'avoue que j'ai du mal à
comprendre le raisonnement donc ses
missions de police elles existent où
elle n'existe pas lorsqu'on motive ce
permis de port d'armes
puisque vous semblez dire que c'est une
reprise formelle je vous ai dit comment
nous les avons qualifié et c'est écrit
nous avons considéré que c'est dans le
cadre de son action de coordination des
services de sécurité de la présidence de
la république en lien avec le gspr et
les forces militaires nous avons
considéré que ça pouvait s'inscrire dans
le cadre général d'une mission de police
oui en fait monsieur drouet pour dire
les choses telles que les a dit le
préfet de police devant nous et un
arrêté ministériel s'est arrêté
ministériel défini les services ou
catégories de services qui accueillent
des fonctionnaires et agents pouvant
être armé au titre des dispositions
légales et réglementaires que vous avez
rappelé évidemment à la présidence de la
république n'est pas mentionnée par cet
arrêté
nonobstant cette
oubli ou là qu'une carence du droit le
préfet de police et ses services ont
estimé que la fonction de monsieur
benalla pouvait être assimilée aux
fonctions qui sont énumérés par l'arrêté
qui détermine les catégories de
fonctionnaires ayant la possibilité
d'avoir une arme de service
si j'ai bien si j'ai bien compris et
donc il est extrêmement important de
constater que c'est parce que vous avez
vous à la préfecture de police était
convaincu que monsieur benalla
exerçaient une fonction de police que
vous avez pu inscrire la délivrance de
ce permis de port d'armes dans le cadre
des textes en vigueur car si vous aviez
estimé au contraire qu'il n'exerçait pas
de fonctions de police
il lui était illégal d'attribuer ce
permis de port d'armes est ce que j'ai
bien interpréter les choses monsieur
drouet
absolument pas monsieur le président
et je reprends les textes de l'article r
300 12-24 il ya bien deux alinéas et les
deux conditions ne sont pas cumulatives
le premier alinéa dispose que les agents
les fonctionnaires et agents des
services publics chargés des missions de
police peuvent être armés
le second alinéa dispose que les allées
fonctionnaires et agents des services
publics exposés à des risques
d'agression dans le cadre de leurs
fonctions peuvent être armés
c'est où et où les deux conditions ne
sont pas cumulatives et donc sans cette
mission de police sans référence à son
action de coordination des services de
l'ap de sécurité de la présidence de la
république
nous aurions pu prendre l'arrêté ils
auraient été légales
alors ils auraient éventuellement était
légale peut-être mais il se trouve que
le préfet de police que nous avons
auditionné lui nous a expliqué qu'il
s'était fondée sur cette activité de
police pour jets sous des yeux ces
déclarations pour délivrer le permis de
port d'armes
donc je comprends qu'on y passe du temps
parce que c'est assez essentiel pour
percevoir quelle était la mission
exercées par monsieur benalla auprès du
chef de l'état et si c'est une mission
de police
alors c'est une mission qui évidemment
interfère avec des services qui sont
sous la responsabilité du gouvernement
et qui doivent assurer la sécurité soit
des déplacements soin de la personne du
chef de l'état mais si vous aviez dû
vous prononcer uniquement sur le
fondement de la protection personnelle
de monsieur benalla vous n'auriez pas eu
besoin de mentionner qu'il avait une
mission de police
or vous l'avez fait ou de droit parce
que dans les éléments qui nous avait été
fourni
il y avait inscrit c'est sa mission de
coordination des services de la sécurité
de la présidence de la république en
lien avec les forces militaires et le
j'espère et nous avons considéré que ça
pouvait assimiler à une mission de
police
c'est un
c'est un choix qui a été fait depuis la
préfecture de police par les services de
la préfecture de police
et nous l'avons assumer et je crois que
le préfet de police l'a effectivement
assumées devant votre commission je vous
remercie mais quels étaient les éléments
fournis qui vous permettait de
considérer qu'il y avait bien une
mission de police vous avez vous le
souvenir de ces éléments précis qui vous
ont été communiqués à l'époque comme je
vous ai dit je n'ai pas pu reconsulter
le le jeu le fait appel qu'à votre le
dossier qui a été saisi par par la
justice la seule chose que je peux vous
dire c'est que les démarches
administratives les procédures
administratives sont basés sur de
l'écrit et donc si nous avons inscrit
cette mission c'est que dans l'écrit et
il y avait mais ça a été d'ailleurs dit
très bien par le chef de cabinet du
président de la république il y avait
son action de coordination des services
de sécurité de la présidence de la
république
je vous remercie madame jourdain pour le
coup ma dernière question sur ce permis
de port d'armes monsieur président bas
rappelait tout à l'heure que le permis
sur le fondement qui avaient été visés
ne pouvait pas être accordée à monsieur
benalla qu'il ne faisait pas partie des
personnels qui était visé précisément
parce fondement juridique
quelles observations avez vous sur ce
point fr je n'ai qu'une observation
c'est que il a été jugé à la préfecture
de police que les missions exercées par
monsieur ben à la rentrée dans le cadre
fixé par le législateur et c'est la
raison pour laquelle le préfet de police
à considérer que l'ensemble des
conditions étaient remplies et que ce
port d'armes pouvaient être autorisés et
c'est la raison pour laquelle cet arrêté
a été signé
je sens bien que vous voulez essayer de
démontrer quelque chose je me limite aux
faits et à la foulée à la procédure
c'est une rue et ne voulant rien
démontrer nous voulons comprendre il y à
des contradictions que nous voulons
lever et si je vous appartient à vous
même de démontrer la position que vous
soutenez avec les éléments d'information
qui sont les vôtres
quant à notre commission elle délibérera
après l'ensemble des auditions pour
déterminer sa propre position
oui elle
un jour deux sujets dans le cadre de vos
fonctions de chef de cabinet du préfet
de police vous avez été amené à avoir
des contacts avec monsieur benalla
question tout à fait j'ai était pour la
première fois en contact avec alexandre
benalla dans le cadre de la préparation
de la soirée du second tour de
l'élection présidentielle à la pyramide
du louvre la soirée du 7 mai 2010 est
ensuite il a intégré l'elysée et nos
relations de travail ont été régulières
jusqu'à mon départ de la préfecture de
police en avril 2018 au gré des
déplacements du président de la
république sur paris c'est en fait tout
simplement le rôle comme je voulais
exposer au début le rôle du chef de
cabinet du préfet de police d'être en
lien étroit avec les autres chefferie de
cabinet du président de la république du
premier ministre et des différents
ministres dans le cadre de la
préparation et l'organisation des
déplacements de leur autorité sur paris
nos relations ont été très cordiale mais
n'ont jamais dépassé le cadre
strictement professionnel
merci selon quelle était la nature des
missions qu'il exerçait à l'elysée
alexandre quesnel a été un membre de la
chefferie de cabinet de la présidence de
la république ce titre il avait en
charge la préparation et l'organisation
des déplacements du président de la
république et donc les liens avec les
préfectures de département de
départements concernés
c'est des fonctions très classique le
lien entre les préfectures et les
cabinets de coordination des différentes
entités qui concourt à l'organisation
d'un déplacement à laon de la logistique
au service presse au service aux
services de sécurité aux services des
préfectures des préfectures concernées
au lien avec les organisateurs
accueillant ça c'était l'émission que je
connaissais d'alexandre benalla dans le
cadre de l'instruction de ce dossier de
port d'armes
j'ai découvert ce qui est de l'un terne
la présidence de la république et que je
ne connaissais pas cette mission de
coordination des services de sécurité la
présidence de la république
je vous remercie vous pouvez continuer
les dernières questions si vous voulez
bien monsieur le président j'avais une
question sur la participation de
monsieur b derrière la manifestation du
1er mai mais je crois que vous y avez
répondu par avance en indiquant que est
en partie vous le 27 avril
vous n'étiez pas informé de cette
participation
pourriez-vous dans un cadre général nous
expliquer quand même quelle est la
chaîne de validation et hiérarchique
lorsqu'une demande d'observation est
adressé à la préfecture de police
monsieur touré civ
la préfecture de police et est une
institution très simple et très
hiérarchisée c'est à dire que tous les
types de demandes remontent au préfet de
police et le préfet de police qui valide
ou non la participation d'un observateur
c'est très régulier que la préfecture de
police
accueil des observateurs sur ces
manifestations c'est le cas de
parlementaires c'est le cas de
journalistes d'étudiants de stagiaires
et si la demande avait été avait été
formulée selon les cadres définis au
sein de la préfecture de police ça
aurait dû remonter soir a dû remonter au
préfet de police
j'ai compris que ça n'avait pas été le
cas je vous remercie donc madame
jourdain
non madame benbassa monsieur grosdidier
effectivement quand je re souligné la
contradiction connaît entre les
différentes déclarations entre ce que
monsieur benalla nous a assuré ce matin
ne justifiait son port d'armes que pour
des raisons de protection personnelle et
cet arrêté qui mentionne son rôle en
matière de sécurité alors quand on
limite à la coordination je ne savais
pas pour coordonner des services il
fallait une arme et posez peut-être le
pistolet sur la tempe de ce qu'on doit
coordonner quoi tout ça tout rien n'est
cohérent et je voudrais savoir c'est qui
est à l'origine de la formulation
quand on pose la question à monsieur ben
ali c'est pas moi qui rédige l'arrêter
le directeur de deux cabinets assume
parfaitement de la présence d'un public
assume parfaitement l'avoir demandé et
qui vont sous quelle forme on devrait
savoir qu'il a rédigée pourquoi comment
excusez moi mais mais mais se pousser
point n'est toujours pas clair ensuite
je souhaiterais savoir à quelle
fréquence
combien de fois effectivement monsieur
benalla s'est rendue à la préfecture de
police de paris lorsqu'il a été en
fonction
certains nous l'ont décrit comme
omniprésent d'autres disent qu'ils
étaient présentés entre monsieur n'a
lui-même en tout et pour tout je crois
cinq fois voilà deux fois avant voilà
donc effectivement et fréquente à
quelles occasions et pourquoi
et est-ce qu'il ya une traçabilité de
toutes les entrées à la préfecture de
police si cela devait être vérifiée
mathieu drouet qui a rédigé l'arrêter ce
sont les services de la préfecture de
police de la direction de l'apple la
police générale
donc c'est très clairement la préfecture
de police qui endosse la responsabilité
des termes qui ont été utilisés
dans cette danse est arrêté quant à la
fréquence des visites de monsieur
benalla à la préfecture de police
je n'ai souvenir à titre personnel que
deux je réfléchis mais que de deux ou
trois de ses visites
la première visite je voulais 10 dont
j'ai souvenir c'était dans le cadre de
la préparation de la soirée du second
tour de l'élection présidentielle donc
début mai 5 ou 7 4 ou 5 mai de 2010 est
là les suivantes parce qu'il y en a eu
plusieurs
c'était dans le cadre de la préparation
du one planet subite qui s'est passé sur
à boulogne billancourt le nouvel
ensemble boulogne billancourt où nous
allons travailler avec les services de
la présidence de la république et
monsieur benalla était présent ce sont
les deux seules visites que j'ai à ma
connaissance mais dont certaines pas
être frustré de de l'arrêt pendant que
ces sont les services des préfectures de
police qui ont imaginé ou conçues comme
monsieur planète est chargé de mission
de coordination de la sécurité parce que
dans la note de service décrivant son
activité
c'était que l'organisation des
déplacements publics et privés et
éventuellement les réceptions à la
présence d'ateliers je vais expliquer à
monsieur drouet pourquoi nous faisons
ces questions parce qu'il est possible
il a beaucoup de travail qui dit pas
assisté à toutes nos éditions
bien qu'elle soit publique mais sachez
monsieur drouet que la définition
formelle qui nous a été donné dès
fonctions de monsieur benalla lors de
nos premières auditions à la fin du mois
de juillet en début du mois d'août
comportait exclusivement trois points la
participation à l'organisation des
déplacements publics du président de la
république
l'organisation
2d de l'accueil des visiteurs pour le 14
juillet car car ils sont très nombreux
et le troisième point c'était
l'organisation n'ont pas seulement la
participation mais l'organisation des
déplacements privés du chef de l'état ou
de son épouse
et ça n'est que et sané oui c'est cela
c'était sa responsabilité en propre
voilà l'explication que vous adonner sur
sa fonction
puis plus récemment on nous a dit c'est
dès la semaine dernière le chef de
cabinet du président de la république
il avait aussi une fonction de
coordination du gspr et du commandement
militaire du palais je crois que dans
l'esprit de la description de cette
fonction de coordination ça ne veut pas
dire que le coordinateur comme peut
l'être le coordinateur du renseignement
national se situer au sommet de la
pyramide mais que dans la pratique du
fonctionnement quotidien
il avait à jouer un rôle de trait
d'union et voilà que cette semaine on
nous explique que alors il nous avons
pensé que sa facilité la justification
du port d'armes qu'ils exercent une
mission de sécurité mais cette semaine
fait nouveau monsieur benalla lui même
vous aussi vous nous indiquez que non ça
n'était pas pour une fonction de
sécurité c'était pour sa protection
personnelle
on se demande qu'est ce qui spécifie que
l'on pouvait bien exposé à ce poids
monsieur benalla à des risques puisque
il avait une fonction qu on nous a
décrite comme une fonction
d'organisation et même la coordination
comme une fonction que dont il ne faut
pas exagérer l'importance hiérarchique
qui ne plaçait pas au dessus de dés des
chefs du j'espère ou du commandant
commandant militaire du palais voilà
pourquoi monsieur grosdidier
assises pour essayer de comprendre parce
que finalement il y a eu des versions
évolutives du du de la mission exacte de
monsieur benalla et dans toutes ses
versions reste une énigme
mais pourquoi donc avait t-il besoin
d'une arme il nous a dit lui même qu'il
pouvait avoir sur lui cette arme en
présence du chef de l'état soit dans des
déplacements privés soit en dessous dans
des placements publics qu'il le pouvait
l'amener à l'elysée vous n'avez pas à
nous répondre sur ce que faisait
exactement monsieur b nana puisque vous
n'êtes pas censé le savoir en revanche
la préfecture de police étaient censés
avoir des éléments objectifs suffisant
pour pouvoir affirmer dans l'arrêté
autorisant le port d'armes que monsieur
benalla exercer une fonction de police
s'est passé voilà je vous laisse
répondre à mes questions de monsieur
grosdidier
après avoir essayé de vous donner le
contexte de cette question parce que
nous n'avons pas encore à ce jour réussi
à avoir une vision parfaitement clair de
et de 7,2 cette fonction alors allez-y
monsieur deux roues et si vous pouvez
nous avons un petit complément
d'information il sera le bienvenu
monsieur pardon monsieur de complément
voyez-vous monsieur yann drouet
nous entendons beaucoup de personnes qui
nous exposent des choses et au bout d'un
moment j'ai envie de vous demander quel
est votre sentiment intime profond votre
conviction
on a peut-être à tort le sentiment qu'on
nous expose de beaucoup de manières d
minimisation du rôle de monsieur benalla
mais qu'en réalité il était l'homme de
confiance qui à cet égard disposer d'un
pouvoir très large jusqu'à être
finalement peut-être j'emploie cet
adverbe riez vous
le maître d'oeuvre d'une réorganisation
de la sécurité du chef de l'état dans
toutes ses dimensions
quand bien même ce serait en opposition
avec le ministère de l'intérieur
et vous vous avez comme nos lu cette
phrase entre guillemets dans le journal
du dimanche je pense le dimanche vous
lisez le journal du dimanche
oh il fait état lui même de l'opposition
du ministère de l'intérieur pas si vous
voyez le l'adjoint au chef de cabinet du
chef de l'état qui dit ben voilà le
ministère de l'intérieur est opposé à
mes visions et en tant que fonctionnaire
de la république qu'est ce que vous
pensez tout ça alors monsieur des céans
j'ai été convoqué en tant qu'ancien chef
de cabinet du préfet de police et donc
c'est que en tant qu'ancien chef de
cabinet du préfet de police donc
fonctionnaires que je vais vous répondre
monsieur le sénateur je voudrais réagir
à ce que dit monsieur grosdidier est ce
que vous avez dit dans l'arrêté la
mention portant à l'action de
coordination des services de sécurité de
la présidence de la république en lien
avec le gspr une force de sécurité
c'est donc dans le dossier qui nous
avait été fourni que nous avons trouvé
cette mention et c'est de cette mention
que nous avons estimé
nous avons jugé que ça pouvait être
assimilée à une mission de police
mais il ne faut pas isoler les choses
c'est ce que je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure dans la façon nous avons examiné
le dossier c'est un ensemble et donc on
a considéré son action de coordination
des services de sécurité de la
présidence
on a
estimé qu'il exerçait sa mission auprès
du président de la république une des
personnalités les plus menacées de
france dans un contexte de menaces
terroristes des plus élevés et on a
considéré que dans le cadre de ses
fonctions dans le cadre de sa mission il
était manifestement exposés à des
risques c'est l'ensemble qu'on a
considéré c'est l'ensemble qu'on a
considéré monsieur le président je vous
remercie
j'entends bien que c'est le
l'appréciation que vous défendez et nous
verrons si la commission accepte de s'en
convaincre
mais alors est ce que madame jourdain
d'autres questions monsieur sur hatem
d'autres questions moi je voudrais
revenir à la question de la décision
prise de d'autoriser monsieur benalla ou
même de l'inviter à assister en tant qu
observateur au service d'ordre de la
manifestation du 1er mai parce que j'ai
compris de précédentes auditions que le
préfet de police n'avait pas été informé
de cette participation puis d'autres
témoignages nous on a indiqué qu'au
cours d'un déjeuner du 25 avril auquel
vous avez participé avec le général bio
pas monsieur deux roues et auquel ont
participé à certain nombre de
protagonistes la participation de
monsieur benalla à ce service d'ordre
comme observateurs avaient été évoqués
et notamment en présence d'un
fonctionnaire cadre de la préfecture de
police
est ce que il s'agit de monsieur
simoneau est ce que vous même
à cette date ou dans les jours qui ont
précédé le 1er mai avait été informé de
cette participation de monsieur benalla
en qualité d'observateurs qui semblait
parfaitement acquise depuis plusieurs
jours déjà par un représentant de la
préfecture de police
très clairement non monsieur le
président je vous remercie
tu es maintenant proposer à mes autres
collègues de poser leur question madame
de la gombe
merci président donc effectivement
monsieur le chef de cabinet on voit que
l'administration a très bien fonctionné
puisque en neuf jours entre le jour de
la présentation bichet comme vous le
dites et l'octroi du permis
l'afer a été instruite même si vous le
précisez c'est le seul cas où un
collaborateur de l'elysée a demandé un
port d'armes pendant les deux ans et
demi vous avez été présents à ce poste
donc c'était assez exceptionnel mais
vous avez indiqué autre chose est-ce que
vous pouvez confirmer que donc lorsque
la préfecture de police est saisie d'une
demande de port d'armes
le ministère de l'intérieur n'est jamais
interrogé pour savoir si une demande a
été formulée auprès de ses services
première question la deuxième question
c'est avez vous eu connaissance de
menaces dont monsieur benalla aurait
fait l'objet
et vous comprenez bien que c'est lié au
fait qu' il semble donc que ce soit la
seule personne à l'elysée qui soit dans
cette situation puisqu'elle est la seule
personne à pour amender un port d'armes
il ya d'ailleurs une curiosité à placer
auprès du président de la république
quelqu'un de menacer
monsieur zuma vous avez en partie
répondu à la première question mais
peut-être que vous pourriez re re re
mettre les choses au clair sur la
première question comme je l'aï indiqué
on est sur des fondements juridiques
différents les peintres des fondements
juridiques différents c'est le stricte
compétence du préfet territorialement
compétent et il n'a pas interrogé le
ministère de l'intérieur
je peux pas ma connaissance non la
sénatrice sur la seconde question
excusez moi ça m'a menacé sur cette
question je ne suis pas habilité à moi
bien je vous remercie et je voudrais
donner la parole maintenant monsieur ce
bois vincent segouin merci monsieur le
président euh ça a été pas mal repris
mais je voulais juste reformuler un peu
parce qu'on est fait vous nous expliquer
mais je trouvais je voulais revenir sur
l'arrêté du permis de port d'armes
visionnée par la préfecture monsieur
benalla donc à demander un permis port
d'armes
uniquement pour sa sécurité personnelle
vous nous expliquer enfin on nous a
expliqué doctement pourtant on nous a
aussi expliqué ce matin au cours de
toutes les auditions que monsieur nana
est en permanence en à côté du président
sur son épaule droite pour reprendre ses
propos pour assurer la coordination
[Musique]
si si on lui octroie un permis de port
d'armes pour sa sécurité personnelle et
qu'il est à côté du président est-ce
qu'il n'augmente pas le risque de
sécurité au soudan la personne du
président c'est ça ma question est la
première et puis est ce que la
préfecture
à partir du moment où on respecte
l'article que vous avez mentionné à
plusieurs reprises ne s'inquiète pas
plus du bon sens de la sécurité et
ne va pas plus loin dans l'octroi du
permis de port d'armes monsieur drouet
la préfecture examine examinant droit
les choses et pour être très clair ce
n'est pas pour sa sécurité personnelle
que le port d'armes lui a été octroyé
c'est dans le cadre de ses missions de
sa fonction de la mission qu'on a
considéré comme étant une mission de
police de coordination et du fait qu'il
est dans le cadre de ses fonctions
donc c'est pas à titre personnel dans le
cas de ses fonctions manifestement
exposés à des risques d'agression au
regard du niveau de la menace
effectivement ça ne me paraît pas
aberrant de considérer de considérer
cela merci monsieur drouet monsieur
piles et oui monsieur le président ce
président vous corrigerez immédiatement
et mes collègues éventuellement si j'ai
commis une erreur en n'écoutant mal ce
qui a été dit ce matin par monsieur
benalla mais je crois bien que monsieur
benalla nous a très clairement dit qu'il
n'avait jamais déposé
matériellement de demande et que seul un
coup de fil de
ce strzoda avait déclenché la procédure
or vous venez de nous dire qu'il y a
bien eu une demande classique fait par
le guichet de la préfecture de police
qui avaient été déposés ce qui n'a pas
du tout été présenté comme ça ce matin
est ce que vous avez souvenir vous
souvenez que cette demande a bien été
signé par monsieur benalla d'ailleurs je
ne pense pas que ça puisse pas ça puisse
être un imprimé non signé et nous dira
si alan ex d'une telle demande et un
certain nombre de pièces qui doivent
être fournies contrat de travail des
stations sur l'honneur de stations de
moralité que sais-je et qui doivent être
fournis à l'appui de la demande initiale
de monsieur benalla sur laquelle il a
été attiré l'attention par la suite
mathieu drouet je vais vous répondre je
me souviens quand je me souviens c'est
que ce que j'ai heureux avec mes propres
archives essayer de remonter les choses
le 5 octobre 2017
je suis informé par les services de la
préfecture de police de la direction la
police générale que monsieur et nahla a
déposé une demande la forme de cette
demande
je suis je ne suis pas capable je ne
suis pas capable de vous répondre
ensuite ce qui est jeu je ne suis pas en
mesure de vous dire je n'ai pas eu j'en
ai pas eu comme ils ont qu'elle aurait
dû être écrite
la procédure nous l'avons fait rentrer
dans le cadre de ce qu'elle devait être
c'est à dire qu'il ya une demande qui a
été faite ou au guichet c'était dans le
cadre de ses fonctions
donc ça devait finir par l'autorité
hiérarchique nous avons saisi l'autorité
hiérarchique qui nous l'a confirmé la
demande est demandé d'instruire un
dossier papier et je vous remercie jeu
nous entendons entre les lignes j'espère
un de ses papiers transmis de mémoire le
10 octobre 2010 est très bien je vous
remercie
alors monsieur kerrouche oui tout tourne
au cours autour de cette demande de port
danse de ça devient un petit peu de
mystère de la chambre jaune à la
préfecture de police
si je comprends bien et si je vous suis
donc le la mention du pouvoir de police
n'étaient pas utiles pour le port
d'armes
mais néanmoins elle n'était pas utile
parce qu'il y avait un deuxième motif
mais néanmoins il a quand même été jugé
utile de faire mention explicitement de
cette notion de pouvoir de police de
telle façon que si je comprends bien
également le la réflexion qui a été
menée
on ne peut pas savoir si c'est sur cette
base ou sur l'autre que le père me
tordre a été délivré c'est à dire que en
gros ça peut être l'une ou l'autre si je
vous suis bien la menace qui pesait sur
monsieur benalla d'une part ont
éventuellement la question du pouvoir de
police dans le cadre de ses fonctions
pour lui attribuer mais que c'est les
deux l'une ou l'autre mais qu' a priori
d'après ce que vous nous dites ça serait
plutôt les deux quand bien même le pays
le père me tord dame aurait pu être
attribués pour un cas ou pour l'autre
est-ce que je suit là messieurs drouet
vous êtes l'air monsieur le sénateur je
vous confirme que nous auriez vous pu
nous référer simplement au premier
alinéa ou simplement au second alinéa de
l'article r 300 12-24 au regard des
éléments qu'on avait en notre possession
dans le dossier on a considéré qu'on
pouvait faire référence aux deux alinéas
donc celui qui fait référence aux
missions de police et celui qui fait
référence aux risques d'agression dans
le cadre de dans le cadre des fonctions
validant par là-même donc la mission de
police de merida validant par là même
nous avons qualifié ces missions de
police je ne sommes pas limités à
marquer missions de police nous avons
qualifié dans l'arrêté dans le
considérant en disant que ces missions
police dans le cadre de son action de
coordination des services de sécurité de
la présidence de la république en lien
avec les france militaire et le gspr cet
écrit mais merci de cette réponse
maintenant nous avons madame lherbier
vous pouvez monsieur chef de cabinet moi
ce qui m'intéressait c'est de savoir
s'il y avait un protocole bien établi
bien-être concernant les vidéos quand il
y à une des manifestations et des
rencontres publiques
si on détecte quoi que ce soit calé le
la démarche officielle qui est
[Musique]
interpellé qui est renseigné sur ce
convoi de deux suspects en général
est-ce que ça se fait automatiquement
est-ce que ça se fait souvent comment
comment vous procéder dans le dans
l'état major qui organise la vidéo des
manifestations et des rencontres
publiques
mais si le trouver la préfecture de
police et une grande maison il ya
plusieurs état-majors plusieurs salles
de commandement en fonction des
directions concernées
il ya deux salles de commandement à la
direction de l'ordre public et de la
circulation la démo pc
il y à une salle de commandement à la
direction de la sécurité de proximité de
l'agglomération parisienne il ya une
salle de commandement à la dostl il ya
une salle de commandement à la drpj et
une salle de commandement à la drpp
chacun chacune de ces directions et
chacune de ces salles de commandement
est équipé des outils de vidéos
[Musique]
protection ces outils de vidéoprotection
servent à être en relation avec les
effectifs qui sont sur le terrain et
donc si un opérateur
si un opérateur voix sur ses écrans une
action manifestement délictuelles il
doit informer les effectifs sur place et
pour qu'ils nous donnent suite sur place
voilà je sais ce que j'ai compris de
votre question je suis et monsieur le
président si je peux dire mais l'homme
lherbier tout simplement rien ne peut
échapper à à cette surveillance vidéo ce
que je voulais savoir bien merci
bien sûr beaucoup de choses échappent à
la surveillance vidéo je vous remercie
monsieur jean pierre sueur le même état
d'esprit bien que vous n'étiez plus bien
que vous ne faisiez plus en fonction le
1er mai au soir
il ya donc une réunion de commandement
plus haut niveau et oui je sais mais ces
réunions plus haut niveau il ya le
ministre le préfet de police
ja je suppose des gens qui sont invités
à participer
est ce que le chef de cabinet n'est pas
tenu au courant ne gère pas les inviter
à votre avis parce que vous voyez il y à
laquelle c'est clair que ça arrive
est-ce que c'est prévu
est ce qu'il est une liste des invités
on peut venir à l'improviste à ces
réunions d'état-major
emmenés par un collègue non non c'est
des salles sécurisées il ya des badges
d'accès pour accéder à ces à ces salles
donc on ne peut pas
il y arriver comme ça de façon à
l'improviste toute personne extérieure
est forcément accompagné et invite donc
et qui invite qui invite alors que qui
invite elle dans les salles de
commandement là pour le coup c'est pas
tout le temps le préfet de police qui
étaient invités les directions ont leur
ont leur propre autonomie peuvent
inviter des encore une fois beaucoup de
personnes des journalistes sont invités
à voir ces salles des parlements
d'ériger à bienne fonctionnaires
d'autorité qui prend la décision
d'inviter ou de laisser entrer tel ou
tel affirmatif et ce fonctionnaire idée
de quel niveau
j'imagine que la question que vous me
posez très la direction de leur public
et de la circulation
c'est forcément quelqu'un de
l'état-major de la direction de leur
public et la circulation je vous
remercie
alors maintenant nous avons une question
de monsieur bonnecarrère oui merci merci
monsieur chef kevin et je reviens
quelques secondes à l'autorisation de
deux ports d'armes que vous avez signé
par délégation du préfet de police et je
voudrais examiner quelques secondes par
la pensée l'élément central de l'évier
administrative française qui est le
parapheur quand vous avez signé cet
arrêté donc il est arrivé dans un
parapheur je vois deux hypothèses
hypothèse une vous êtes de le décideur
et vous ont été remis deux projets
d'arrêtés un projet d'arrêté accordant
l'autorisation
un projet d'arrêté refusant
cette autorisation hypothèse une
hypothèse de ne vous est arrivé dans le
parapheur que le projet d'arrêté
favorable à la délivrance de
l'autorisation de par da
mais souvent il y avait forcément de
l'autre côté du parapheur la petite note
d'accompagnement de vos services
expliquant pourquoi vous deviez les
signes et dans une grande maison telle
qu'elle nous a été présentée extrêmement
hiérarchisée il y avait forcément des
visas des chefs de service successifs
sur cette note dont est ce que vous
pouvez me dire comment se présenter
l'arrêté de parapheurs kg moment où vous
avez à poser votre précieuse signature
monsieur trou et ça a été dit a été dit
dans les échanges s'étaient pas courant
il ya un collaborateur de la présidence
face ce type de demande et donc cette
demande a été traitée a été traitée avec
beaucoup d'attention et nous avons
traité au niveau du cabinet
l'instruction l'instruction du dossier
qui a été validé
l'instruction du dossier a été validée
par le préfet de police après la
validation par le préfet de police le
préfet de police a validé le dossier et
à partir de là les services ont rédigé
ont rédigé les actes
et comme dans tous les départements les
membres de corps préfectoral dans l'est
dans chacun de vos départements ont
chacun des délégations de signature du
préfet territorialement compétent le
chef de cabinet du préfet de police a
également une délégation de signature et
donc c'est dans le cadre de cette
délégation de signature que j'ai signé
l'arrêté
parce que et on est dans une maison
tenue à la préfecture de police parce
que le préfet de police avait validé le
dossier
merci monsieur joué monsieur du rhin oui
monsieur droit je ne suis pas comme
d'autres sans doute très familiers des
questions de sécurité et de police et je
voudrais avoir votre avis sur un sujet
qui ne présente pas une très grande
technicité mais comme vous avez vu les
choses de l'intérieur
ça résume ramon sentiment du matin après
l'ensemble des auditions est ce que pour
faire un travail de policier il ne vaut
pas mieux être policier soi même j'ai
trouvé une question facile à la police y
est soi même très certainement oui mais
à ma connaissance monsieur benalla n'a
jamais exercé le métier de policier
police tout est clair merci alors je
vous remercie je vous remercie nous
avons maintenant la question de madame
catherine di folco merci monsieur le
président c'est pas vraiment une
question d'ailleurs mais je rebondis sur
votre dernière parole nous dit monsieur
bénin n'a jamais été policier j'ai quand
même le souvenir quand nous avons
auditionné monsieur collomb il m'a dit
j'ai toujours pensé qu'il était policier
jeu simplement c'est un clin d'oeil mais
ma remarque était la suivante
et peut-être que c'est une information
pour vous mais monsieur
monsieur b nana benalla nous a dit ce
matin clairement qu'il n'utilisait son
arme que pour aller de son domicile ou
travail et du travail au domicile donc
c'est sur cette période là qu'ils se
sentent le qui se sentait le plus menacé
et donc c'est hors fonction c'était une
remarque alors je ne sais pas si vous
voulez réagir à l'intervention de notre
de notre collègue et madame train de
l'est merci monsieur le président
simplement je souhaiterais avoir une
précision mais vous n'allez peut-être
pas me répondre
monsieur ban benalla nous l'avons tous
compris exercer des missions hautement
stratégique à l'elysée et de ce fait là
étaient exposés à des risques tout à
fait particulier qui ont justifié le
fait qu'il est important
je pense enfin j'espère que ces mêmes
missions qui ont été exercées par
monsieur benalla hier seront exercés ou
sont déjà exercé par d'autres personnes
aujourd'hui monsieur locher est
particulièrement exposé aussi puisque il
était son supérieur hiérarchique et
lui-même étaient régulièrement surtout
les déplacements auprès du président de
la république
aujourd'hui vous êtes à l'elysée est ce
que vous seriez susceptible de proposer
la personne qui va remplacer monsieur
benalla de faire une demande de port
d'armes ou alors à ce moment-là que
pensez-vous de la dune du développement
d'une stratégie de 2 comment de
protection tout à fait particulière pour
l'ensemble des personnes qui
travailleront sur les missions exercées
par monsieur ban benalla monsieur drouet
je ne peux pas répondre à cette question
c'est donc votre réponse très bien
monsieur trou et je vous remercie et
bien que vous ne puissiez pas répondre à
la dernière question d'avoir coopéré
avec notre commission des lois cette
audition est maintenant terminé la
séance est levée